toys and games are things that remind us
all of our own individual childhoods but
sometimes they go out of fashion that's
not always the end of the story though
because sometimes they go back into
fashion allowing a new generation to
discover them make sure you watch to the
end to find out how a 90s classic is
taking kids today by storm if this is
your first time visiting us at the
things then you should give this video a
like and hit that subscribe button today
we're looking at old games that are
wildly popular again Super Nintendo one
of the best-selling most successful and
best loved video game consoles of all
time is the Super Nintendo Entertainment
System this system helps define the
16-bit era as gaming although to
modernize its graphics and sounds can
seem to be a bit old-fashioned they were
cutting edge when it was released in the
early 1990s its mode 7 graphics feature
meant some games had a spiraling
rotating feeling that is still
remembered as being ahead of its time
today did you know that the system was
called the Super Famicom in Japan that's
because the old Nintendo Entertainment
System the 8-bit NES was called the
Famicom there and in case you're
wondering why that was called that it's
short for family computer
despite the sheer popularity of the SNES
it was so popular that its main rival
Sega trailed way behind it
although Sega's Genesis the 16-bit
machine known as the Mega Drive in the
UK told 29 million consoles that figure
was dwarfed by the SNES is 49 point 1
million but as times changed Nintendo
changed with them and with new systems
like n64 game cube and we the SNES
became obsolete but when Nintendo
announced it would be making an
all-in-one SNES mini one in 2017 it was
hugely successful the console sold out
in a matter of days as people shelled
out to play the games that had kept
people in thrall 25 years before hey
guys we are so excited to announce here
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIYs fashion tips
makeup hacks and so much more we are
sure you're going to love it
and be sure to let us know what you
think in the comment section she let me
hear from you see you there
My Little Pony My Little Pony was a
genuine 80s classic of children's toys
the little figures were a gigantic
success launching in 1983 the little act
line figures sold millions of copies all
around the world and spawned an iconic
children's TV show
however times change and so do trends
and by 1991 kids the vast majority of
whom were girls had moved on from the
toys and while there were attempts to
relaunch them in the late 1990s and
early 2000s it seemed as if they would
never recreate their iconic status they
had enjoyed when they first came out but
that was before the My Little Pony
Friendship is Magic cartoon series came
out it was this show that reignited the
brand and wanted a whole new generation
of fans in the process this meant in
turn that new toys based on the cool
stylized psychedelic new ponies were
once again a must-have item people were
not expecting that nor some of the new
fans the brand was attracting we think
that the biggest surprise was that My
Little Pony so often seen as a thing for
girls would attract a range of male fan
known as bronies these young and not so
young men helped blow apart gender
stereotypes and now it was both boys and
girls playing with My Little Pony Furby
when it comes to crossing over
traditional soft toys with high-class
technology we don't think anyone has
ever bettered the Furby these toys were
a big big deal back in the late 90s they
were fluffy and they look sort of like a
cross between a hamster and an owl but
that wasn't all
no fur bees made by toy giant Hasbro
could also interact with you they spoke
a strange language called furbish but as
you played with them and interacted with
them they would pick up words in English
too when your Furby told you that it
loved you trust us your heart melted
they were so big their success had some
unintended consequences for instance
there was a belief that fur bees could
record certain words this was
understandably a bit of a concern in
places where it may not have been a good
idea to have things committed to tape or
Furby one of these places was the
American national secure
agents Washington bosses were so
concerned about this that in 1999 staff
were banned from bringing their Kirby's
into the office
however the worries were unfounded
because actually Kirby's weren't able to
record things but it looked like these
robot toys were in some way losing their
edge but that was until 2012 when a new
line of Kirby's was brought out changes
in technology meant that they could be
linked with smartphone technology this
meant that a whole new generation was
able to enjoy furbies guests who here at
the thing that we do enjoy trying to
solve a puzzle and work out someone's
identity we're pretty good at it if we
may say so ourselves some of our team
like to put it down to hours of playing
the classic game
guess who when we were kids if you've
never played it here's how it worked
there are two players each one of them
has to pick a card with someone's face
on it both players have a board with 30
different paces on them and they have to
try to work out which person they've got
based on their appearance trust us it's
really good fun it was something that
children who grew up in the 1980s loved
there's an argument to be made that it
was the last great family board game
before video game consoles sprung up
everywhere but video games and other
newer games meant that the popularity of
guess who declined in the 1990s it
probably didn't help that the game could
have had a bit more diversity at one
point there were 19 male characters but
there were only 5 female faces to choose
from however the game managed to revamp
and renew itself and managed to get some
special editions franchises like Disney
Star Wars and even Burger King have all
got in on the action Tamagotchi if you
grew up in the 1990s then we think
there's a really big chance you owned a
Tamagotchi these virtual pets were
everywhere in case you don't know what a
Tamagotchi is I'll tell you it was a
small oval-shaped LED computer screen on
a keyring and on the screen there was a
little cartoon pet what you had to do
was to feed your Tamagotchi you know
factor it play with it and make sure it
got enough sleep sounds simple enough
but here's the big thing if you didn't
look after it properly your Tamagotchi
would die and when that happened it was
absolutely heartbreaking so you had to
make sure that you gave it its medicine
if it got sick - it was a fun challenge
and one which millions of people
responded to across the world
however like so many other things
Tamagotchis became less ubiquitous as
the
went on they were still being made by
Japan's Bandai company but they weren't
as big a deal as they had been when they
came out in 1996 but all that changed in
October 2017 that's when old fashioned
Tamagotchis just like the ones that
became famous more than 20 years before
were released suddenly everyone got
their own Tamagotchis again but that got
us wondering what else from the 1990s
would you like to see make a comeback
don't be shy let us know in the comments
and that's all for our old games that
are wildly popular again if you enjoyed
watching this then check out ten paw
patrol dogs all grown up thanks for
watching and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]